back to the d3 square and suddenly
there's this queen 8:7 move and a king
that was one secure no issues whatsoever
is going to get checked quite a bit the
the engine is not even giving a
two-point win here even though black is
up two ropes and two pawns for the Queen
that should be more than enough to say
three points four point edge but now
it's giving less than a two point edge
and its best lines are not that
attractive rook 1 c2 is its first
thought queen 8 7 check King f8 and now
f5 and it's not easy to deal with these
checks that are about to happen to the
king so I'm not sure what is going on
but it looks like Fabiani was playing
his first real sub-optimal move of the
tournament a significant one that it was
that was different from my quality from
other moves that could have been played
and this move F takes on g4 was
absolutely not cool for him and he's
starting to realize that I think as he
stares at the board and an opportunity
maybe for him to get nicked and not have
that perfect score anymore I still think
it's black for choice let's not
overstate the case too much but he could
have won right now and he's not gonna
appreciate it
when this line is shown to him after the
game guys well thank you for that
Maurice I'm still like reeling from the
idea that white does have opportunity to
save the game because it just looked
like for example after king f7 as we're
mentioning it's such a big material add
you would think that black should just
be able to reel the point home clarify
for me why after Queen d3 rook h8 I'm
assuming f5 yes I'm assuming f5 and
let's say I drop back with my rook rook
c6 just to end up trying to protect my
king I guess takes on e6 takes on e6
Queen f5 yeah you're getting some
activity that I would prefer not to have
allowed so that makes sense that White's
queen is suddenly active
an undeserved opportunity I would guess
for he Carroll in that case still I
would be stunned in fact if a Bjorn
didn't win but for sure he's made his
own task harder by having this Bishop h4
I'll grant you that
and though we are in the second time
control still only 15 minutes for five
down on yours
they might get into a little second time
time control time pressure which hasn't
happened for us very much in this thing
field Khafre we have victory even
guiding into the second time in the
first oh yeah really flashing so Levon
Aronian verse magnus carlsen for sure
we've that's kind of fallen off our
screen so let's just see what we had
we'll go back a few moves just a second
where's my there we go I think we left
it after Knight f3 right Jen rook c5
ruby to these moves have been played 92
earlier trying to put the pressure on
the c4 pawn and he interrupted 94 96 as
well exactly preventing that and well
first of all you can't grab this pawn
with the rook there's an obvious oops
removing the defender variation you
can't grab this pawn with the night
because then White's walking into a
devastating pin after for example Bishop
defy and rook c8 so the pawn is
poisonous so knight b3 was tried taking
advantage of the fact that pawn is
pinned the rook on c5 is hanging we have
seen rook e8 returning the favor and I
can't grab the rook because the rook on
b2 is hanging so rook drop back to c2
and c3 I was about to say how's this for
a cute little idea c3 so again you can't
grab the roof because the rook on b2 is
hanging and
guessing rupee one worked me what
happened merely said okay and now Magnus
to close the curtain on this one so
let's say we played I always said this
combination of rook and Bishop versus
rook and Knight so good for the oh we
may even have a tree cheapo how's this
for cheap though how about Bishop efore
it's so good for the rook and Bishop
combination here's what I had in mind by
the way Knight takes rook takes knight
takes and by umm no it's not unfortunate
circumcised I'm sorry
ah the Knights just in time to defend
the promotion square sorry about that
okay I had a hiccup
so Bishop d5 the normal move asking
white what he wants to do in case of
takes takes takes check again we see
this wonderful combination of rook and
Bishop dominating rook and Knight we're
going to pick off one pawn and well
let's just continue the line for a
moment we do have a little bit of a
counter play here with rook and Knight
but no I think I think Magnus is well on
his way here I do think that Magnus is
gonna reel on the point and if that were
to happen are we gonna see three
decisive games again do these guys ever
draw wow what's going on Maurice I'm
still thinking it has Magnus increased
his advantage actually no no it seems as
though LaVon has defended quite well and
in this position it's very hard to get
anything going
you he he's gonna lose his c3 pawn
basically there's no really good move
here rook to c2 b5 as the engines first
choice to just give him the pawn back
and after Bishop to d5 then rook b2 c1
and play this position and it looks as
though the position is going to be this
past a pawn that the engines don't
really like and think that maybe this
positions equal maybe I might be
inclined to agree with you though yes
after this position it is a is it as an
extra pawn after all I guess rook check
trying to get behind the pawn will be
tricky so rook takes is playable yeah
this may be the way to play all right
here here and here
and this kind of ending is notorious for
being Jewish right or school me on this
one yes this is kind of ending that I
know the rook behind the pawn the a pawn
and you're gonna have to figure out how
to get in
I mean rook b5 doesn't work because of
this move and it's hard to get over
without giving up your F pawn what's
happening here well actually it's a
funny funny game
I remember Magnus actually winning rook
and four versus rook and four against
wristlet pawn tamari off because of a
weak pawn on e5 I'm not sure that I
fully understand what I'm missing
Maurice I thought after c3 rook be
warned I thought the move Bishop d5 was
going to give black an advantage what am
I missing
why doesn't the move Bishop d5 instead
of going for that extra pawn variation
that you showed that move struck me as
in blacks favor and I'm surprised the
engines don't consider it knight on the
rim move unfortunately for this line
Knight takes rook takes and now Knight
a4 very romantic rook to be to preparing
to take with a knight and guard the a to
pawn and it doesn't look like you can
make any real progress here in this
position Knight a four very sneaky
Knight day went right missed that one
and so he did play rook from C to B five
maximum he'll get is that rook and pawn
ending that we talked about after rook
takes on c3 and Bishop to d5 and
hopefully for him he'll be able to get
some advantage in an endgame there but
that looks like a tricky end game to win
agreed well we're gonna keep a close eye
on the defensive task here for both 1100
neon and for ikura Nakamura both white
players by the way and we'll be right
back
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
just getting closer
just bride
who's gonna live my dream
i'm magnus carlsen and you're watching
the Sinquefield cup live here from st.
Louis and I'd like to share some
breaking news I've been informed by my
partner Amy Leigh that the millionaire
chest open and we have organized for
October 9th through the 13th at Planet
Hollywood in Las Vegas this fall will be
covered in the New York Times and
tomorrow's a section of the paper the
online edition for those of you who are
subscribed online and we can access it
will appear in a couple of hours tonight
so we feel quite humbled and honored to
be in the New York Times we've been
working really hard to promote this
tournament as a possible way of
promoting chess in the United States and
around the world so those of you are
interested I haven't bought The Times in
a while I'm sure all of you have bought
The Times recently
I'll pick up a copy tomorrow and check
it out or check it out online tonight
guys Thank You Maurice always nice to
have a breakthrough in the New York
Times and get chess in absolutely
exactly when we need more right exactly
and in the meanwhile we're sitting there
looking at a car's game and it's it's
amazing to me that hakarl has basically
been outplayed comprehensively for about
the whole game and suddenly he's in and
with a shout undeservedly so because
that variation that we were looking at
where we're just trying to contain the
Queen with rook h8 it seems like this
move at f5 it's just giving white enough
activity and Fabiano has gone into it a
bit of a thing and look at the times on
the clock
huge diff despair difference to 5 and
Fabiano is realizing that it's not as
simple as he thought he thought it was
just cut and dry over it would have been
that would have been the case if he had
played that move Bishop h4 the quick f5
takes g4 was played instead
and now he's got to win the game all
over again so big big change in this
round five as we getting into the site
second time control indeed and that is
uh it gonna be an issue for Fabiano
because I know that Nick Omar has an
excellent psychological sense and in a
way the position is easier to play for
whites it's like you got either player 5
you're gonna lose right so he's gonna
continue to make quick moves and really
put the pressure on Fabiano exactly his
moves are gonna be forced all the way
down the line and he's just looking to
get an act of Queen in the meanwhile in
the game between number one number two
coming into the tournament as maurice
predicted the players have gotten to
that very ending that maurice said the
the past a pond on a5 obviously only two
results are black is playing for two
results which is a success when you're
black of course at this high level I'm
thinking after check check kicking back
rook goes over and these are very very
difficult positions for black to win if
he does manage to win it it's really
kunos the problem is that black is going
to need to bring his King over to the
king queen sights of that his plan so
that he can promote his pawn or win
White's rook but it takes a lot of time
to move your king over and while the
King's coming over there well you're
gonna lose your king size they're gonna
create this counter player it will often
make you sacrifice precisely 7 and we do
have some moves in the Metamora Fabiano
game so instead of playing the move rook
h8 what Fabiana did do pardon me let me
go back sometimes my return button
doesn't exactly work the way I wanted
instead of trying to stop Queen h7 check
5 you want to play rook c2 with
obviously the obvious intention of
pinning the
ship and maybe playing for a g4 g3 kind
of a tactic well we see immediately
queen h7 check being give gifted the
opportunity to get an active queen hey
Carl didn't hesitate last time as well
but Fabiano did quickly play it's a
prepared response QB a right no Nakamura
back on milk exactly so now what what
Hikaru needs to do is to make sure that
he's got plenty of checks in the
position now what his problem is he's
he's facing a bishop takes d4 type of
threat taking advantage of the the
bishop being pinned to the king and
maybe white should actually just stop
back with his king with King f1 for a
moment because I don't really see any
edge reasons from well maybe I'm I'm
oscillating here I'm thinking maybe f5
actually deserves attention at first I
rejected it because I thought Bishop
takes d4 was going to win the game now
I'm less certain because you see that we
can play queen g6 check the startling
today well it was Queen g8 that threw me
off balance here because I against queen
g6 I have King King d8 but it's this
move Queen g8 that made me hesitate and
I'm no longer sure anymore
Maurice should Hikaru take this precise
moment to lash out with the move fi will
it save his pitous well it looks as
though Fabiano's advantage is shrinking
and shrinking and shrinking it used to
be huge of course Bishop h4 was just
winning some point was over 2 points
that is now it's shrunk down to 1 point
3 for those of you understand a computer
speak that means it's only a pawn and
some change when he's up a massive
amount of material on the board two
rooks versus a queen that's already an
extra material advantage plus the two
strap-ons plus the attack on this King
and your instincts your spidey sense of
defense II eyes did not betray you King
to f1 is the move that the engines say
really puts it to black to figure out
how to coordinate those rooks and Bishop
with a simultaneous attack on the King
and face the wrath of this white Queen
which is going to use the f5 move plus a
bunch of checks in order to harass the
black King this game is very complicated
now it is possible that he is still
winning he definitely has the edge but
it is not the same anymore by a long way
and Nakamura if he can just settle his
nerves and realize that the opportunity
is here he can certainly harass fabiano
quite a bit and make this game much much
harder than he deserved after the way he
played it you could see it in the way
his body language is suggesting that he
has a chance now a puncher's chance and
he's gonna go for it and you know
Nakamura when it's wild that's when he's
at his best and look at that he's got
enough from the board he realizes that
he has a very good chance to save this
game did you play f5 speaking of punters
chances that is one of my dad's a
favorite expression f5
I thought King f1 as a prelude to f5
does f5 have an instant reputation
though and Maurice I wonder guys f5 is
actually a blunder he should have moved
the King first and five and now Bishop
takes on d4 is winning again Bishop
takes d4 if he plays it that is over
again it looks like Nakamura has
definitely messed up he doesn't have a
perpetual anymore with the checks the
King can just march to the other side of
the board and he's gonna go down a full
piece after all these checks
it looks like Khurana has gotten the
chance again to win the game f5 was a
bad move and there's there's just no way
to get out of it look at this King March
all the way and get a little get all the
way on the other side well there's
there's different kinds of moves here
this just being one of them and after
this move he could just put a rook in
the way you could soccer Queen if you
want north to get the bishop back like
this but this is a complete
lost position and Nakamura it looks like
he's gonna go down after Bishop takes d4
after yet a moment just like Bishop h4
was a chance for for karana
King f1 was a chance for Nakamura and
now he's missed it and Bishop takes d4
is just winning so second chance if he
just can analyze his King marching to
the other side he will get his chance to
win the game but his seconds are ticking
down although I think because you know
the difference between 54 and mr. Bates
4 is quite fast [ __ ] of h4 is much
harder it's easier to miss Bishop each
for as much easier to miss and Bishop
takes d4 yeah well I mean you just
played yeah I think it's very clear when
you play the move rook c2 pinning the
bishop your intention is to play Bishop
takes d4 your opponent lets you play it
you just couldn't kind of go through the
urinalysis and confirm that Bishop takes
d4 as a winner bishop h4 harder move to
spot bishop d4 is not a hard move to
spot that's you just following up you
said a now you're gonna say B so I think
f5 so that is a better corollary I mean
because he was human he's been going
after all this active play so maybe he
kind of fell into that trap that we were
talking about that Cara Juana is now
down on time he had over 20 minutes on
the clock so he could slow down a little
bit rather than playing f5 so quickly
for sure and I don't see king f1 is
being a hard move to spot and Bishop
takes before has nabbed it off the board
of course that's a we're back at the
board now how how are you gonna do well
now if you're looking up to the sky
rechecking these calculations but the
board still the position on the board
that the line that Maurice was showing
just simply speaks for herself the King
gets out of Dodge and just goes over
here find sanctuary on the Queen side in
the meantime this rook takes F to check
is hanging over black White's came I
wonder if he was thinking about this
plane takes an e6 in this position with
the pond and trying to make it
interesting in that way
well unfortunately I think you're I
think you just you you're losing your
queen or are you walking is there force
made in the position I kind of be
surprised if there wasn't a force made
right so you're saying Brooks you to
check here right so we're playing King F
for yeah and I guess there's no force
made I was looking at King d6 I found I
thought this was sweet that was a sweet
but unfortunately there's a king a
suddenly it's not so sweet but okay
there's got to be a simple win here F
we're taking a bishop with check after
all come on takes takes let's find it
but I'm wondering if maybe Nakamura
missed something in this variation maybe
you know II might have calculated oh you
know what we've got this is really nasty
we've got a move like Bishop g7 just
blocking the Queen from 97 and the
bishops untouchable so we've got
defensive resources like that we don't
have to keep checking is what you're
saying right I can keep that in reserve
for just a moment the Bishop g7 looks
like it there's got to be other
resources as well to to reel in the
whole point Maurice what do you think
about this in this lime taking any six
perhaps this is what Nakamura had in
mind maybe he did and just so that you
guys don't have to work too hard since
the engine is just saying look it's it's
bad but it's not mate it doesn't see a
mate at all your line yes is just fine
up to this point the simplest move here
the move that is giving us hugely
winning is simply rook g7 and your Queen
has no potential whatsoever and any
checks the King will just come up this
pawn is free that pawns free
you can't fight rook two rooks a bishop
and a gaggle of pawns coming at a king
the Queen just doesn't stand a chance so
this would warrant resignation quite
quickly if Nakamura win for this line I
think that you look at the body language
off Caruana
he's just suddenly changed remember a
second ago his head was
down staring he probably saw options
like King f1 and was calculating it but
as soon as he car we played f5 he's like
what Bishop d4 my King walks I'm back in
business mr. perfect once again guys
thank you big relief for Fabiana to play
Bishop takes d4 and get back a decisive
advantage in that material what you were
just pointing out rook g7 yeah I was
looking at Bishop g7 I don't don't ask
me why a rook g7 much more powerful move
consolidating the overwhelming material
advantage of two bit two rooks and a
Bishop versus Queen so that game is over
and we have some comments from our
Twitter audience Claudia you know so the
National girls Invitational champion
says that on the positive side whether
Carolina or Nakamura wins and American
will get the full point how their share
at this point or at one point well yeah
yeah it's very very patriotic comment
and we also have a Spanish listener who
is commenting that he doesn't like
macklemore's Bluff with 20 minutes more
on the clock it's not proper especially
in such a tactical I be referring to f5
is basically a bluff because in fact it
doesn't work but it's easier to say that
of course when you have the benefit of
computer analysis to be Nakamura getting
caught up in the moment seeing I have a
chance in trying to put pressure on
Fabiano it's possible to relate to that
agreed agreed and I think from from he
Carlos it's circumstance or situation
you know he said he was saying I need to
make a perpetual check I need to get in
that fight he just needed to play a king
f1 preface it all with King f1 we have
some Nakamura fans there in the audience
with the no no John theory Beyonce then
fiancee Maria off to the right looking
really concerned right now about the
position and
sure she's worried she is from Italy as
well we're rooting for four we know
exactly who's very concerned about the
position right now okay and just turning
to our other game for a moment an
interesting decision by Levon Aronian in
this position I he played the move King
H to the crafty move I thought his
intention was indeed to play rook check
and bring his rook as quickly as
possible behind the pond instead he
played the move King g2 eyeballing
perhaps an opportunity of bringing his
King all the way up the King side h4 and
to g5 so the obvious question is did he
make the right choice here and will his
king I provide him enough counter play
while trying while trying to deal with
this passer so let's let's play some
moves for black King over let's play
this move King age four because you
can't you you would be too slow in this
variation this variation the rook would
get behind the pawn for example like
well just this so you can't you can't
take the palm with the rook but you can
go over here or me you could go over
here with your king that's not the move
I want it part of me I want it to it you
should do it in this way so now we'll go
here here on yeah so here
yeah okay I've defended the pond but now
I've got to calculate okay so a pause
because one of these two pawns are going
to be captured let me capture this one
let's take this one
and this looks like enough counterplay
yeah it seemed that way well though it's
yeah I think it is it's been really
close but I think it is so macklemore's
actually played neither of the moves
that we looked at he hasn't played 38 or
takes on e6
instead he play the move Queen to g6
check actually that was the first move I
looked at gen and I just said well after
Queen g6 check I didn't see another
movies after King d8
so I took my move back I think that I
then looked at Queen ghx o Queen g6
check King d8 variation after Queen GA
King c7 in the cut the King is of course
running well last time we were taking on
e6 with your own right so Queen g6 check
happy indeed King d8 as advertised by
that was an easy move for fabula no
defined and then oh nothing more has
simply taken upon ahneesah
with his Queen yes okay Queen takes c6
leaving the situation f2 Bishop rook
takes f2 King up and now let's see how
how we can best reel in the point here
so looks you can recheck
Brooksie three check is a natural and
obvious one King takes g4 now we can
pause because there's no